some students at coronado high skipped
class to protest today they claim sexual
assault allegations made by other
students weren't taken serious enough
joe mueller has been outside coronado
high he's there live with their message
today joe
a crowd of students came out to shine
the light on what they are calling an
ongoing problem hundreds filled the
sidewalk earlier today to protest these
are some post-it notes and some signs
left over from that protest now students
tell me several sexual assault
allegations have been reported and now
they want justice
coronado students came together and held
signs to send a message it's our right
to protest that injustice i spoke to a
few students who say several female
students were recently sexually
assaulted off campus and some say
incidents happen on campus they claim
the accused are other students attending
school here my incident personally
happened on campus other girls have been
off campus we just want justice for the
girls and we want the perpetrators of
these to be
in held responsible we spoke to kylie
norcross who says the district and
police department are not doing enough
and some don't feel safe these women
were sexually assaulted by the student
and they came forward and they were not
they were not given justice the police
told them boys will be boys the district
referred us to henderson police and say
they have no information to share friday
afternoon the department told us they
are investigating the allegations but
cannot provide details i think it is
great that they're taking action
and participating in this students say
they will be back out to protest if
action is not taken i think they both
need to do more not only the school
district but clark county as a whole and
police department needs to step up their
game with everything
now back out here live a couple of
parents did stop by this protest earlier
today we talked to a few uh some did not
even know exactly what this was about
but after hearing about it they were
happy that the students were taking
action reporting live in henderson joe
mohler live local now